hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i wanted to share with you
why i even have this youtube channel
why do i teach people about property
investment why do i write books why do i
run courses and i want you to really
share and have a little part to heart
and just share what my agenda is what my
motivation is and the reason i'm doing
this is because when i was about 17 18
years old
i can remember when i started going to
courses reading books like rich dad poor
dad and thinking
if robert kiyosaki
was so successful and if he was
financially free
and doesn't have to work
what's his motivation
for writing a book teaching others i
couldn't understand it i used to go to
seminars and look at the person on stage
and think
if you're financially free and you don't
have to work
why are you on stage giving up your time
sharing i didn't really understand it it
was just a little niggle that used to go
on at the back of my head and now fast
forward 12 years i'm 30 years old and i
run one of the largest property
education companies i have a youtube
channel i put out videos every day so i
i just figured if you're anything like i
was or if you're anything like me maybe
sometimes you think
what is samuel's motivation so on this
video i wanted to share and reveal and
just really just open up and explain why
so the first reason or the first thing i
want to say is
i used to think that when i became
financially free i would just want to
learn a beach and not have to do
anything ever again however
hand on heart
there is nothing more
boring
mind-numbing and unfulfilling
than just retiring i remember when me
and amanda had our first child ruby ruby
joy leeds and i took six months off work
and at the end of the six months
i was so
bored and unfulfilled and i didn't i
just lost my umph and amanda was saying
to me you need to get out the house so
one of the reasons is
that when you are financially free it
doesn't mean that you're just not going
to do anything it doesn't mean that
you're going to just be at home be on a
beach be on holiday all the time because
that is actually quite boring so one of
the reasons that i teach is because i
actually really enjoy it i love writing
i find it fulfilling when i see people
succeed when i see people win as a
result of my teaching for me that's part
of my legacy so that's the first reason
the second reason that i teach is
because i make a lot of friends i do a
lot of joint venture i do a lot of
business and i make a lot of friendships
success
you might think that when you become
successful everybody wants to be your
friend
and
all the you know all your old school
friends are going to crawl out the
woodworks and be like man let's buy
around
you're going to get all the ladies i
mean i'm married and i've been married
to six years anyway
but actually
i can only speak from my experience and
in britain certainly
i think the more successful you get
actually the more lonely you get
i think he's i think that's fair to say
from my
experience when you're running a company
i run a company right now we've got
about 31 members of staff
my employees will go out for lunch
together they're all friends
but me because i'm the owner of the
company there's a certain level of
loneliness to that
and that's just not the case in the
company if you if you're a property
investor if you become financially free
and you leave your job everyone wants to
leave their job when you actually do
leave your job
everybody else is working
your friends your family
your ex-schoolmates and the more money
you make and the more successful you
actually alienate yourself from other
people
and it does become really lonely so
the second reason i teach
is because not only do i enjoy it but
also
the friends that i make from training
most of my best friends like ricky for
instance alistair all my friends
were my students
they become successful they leave their
jobs they become financially free and
then they become my friend so the second
reason i teach is because
it's really not just fulfilling but on a
social level on a connecting level with
people i actually find it really
rewarding and it makes me feel less
lonely so that's another reason that i
teach
third reason that i teach is because and
i know what some of you are thinking
some of you thinking samuel when are you
going to get to the money part
i'll get to the money part i'll talk
about the money because some of my
training is advanced and i'm going to
talk about that in a moment but the
third reason i teach is because
when i started out in property investing
a lot of people
a lot of trainers and mentors
were so
boring
in my opinion i've got adhd i'm dyslexic
when i was at school my teachers when i
left school i'd be chatting to be that
make it so complicated and then when i'd
finally understand it i think
why don't you just explain it like this
and i
and i do feel like i've got a gift of
communication and a lot of people would
speak in riddles that make it look
really complicated to make themselves
look smart or maybe to deliberately stop
people doing it and i think that
complexity is the thief of execution and
when i was like 18 19 20 and as i was
learning i remember just thinking man
when i become successful i i just want
to teach i want to share i feel like
it's my duty
in terms of finance and money
do i get paid well to be a trainer do i
get paid a lot to be a youtuber um
so i'll put the facts on the table i
mean for my youtube channel doesn't
really make any money at all i don't
have sponsors
hardly on the channel very rarely do i
have ads on the channel so i think in
total over the last six years of doing
youtube i've maybe made about 4 000
pounds so the youtube and the books and
all that stuff doesn't really make a lot
of money at all
my advanced training courses some of
them do cost thousands of pounds i think
if you do all of my property investment
training you do it as part of the
academy bundle it comes down to about 12
000 pounds which you might think wow
that's a lot of money and i have had
hundreds of academy members that you've
seen on winners on a wednesday
however
my training company has lost money more
years than made money so it's not as
profitable as a lot of people would
think and that's just because of the
resources that i put into it so when you
join the advanced training the support
the mentoring
all of the resources the hotels
everything it costs a lot of money so in
actual terms of profit um it's not as
profitable as some might think however
hey if it was i think that'll be a
really good thing i don't think there'd
be anything wrong with if you're
offering a good service and i think
getting paid well would be perfectly
fine
um as it happens i don't take a salary
even from the training company
sometimes it loses money sometimes it
makes a little money but you should
reinvest that back into the business to
provide a better service my clients so
the money side of things isn't a big
motivator for me in fact
my property business even
i am motivated by making money don't get
me wrong i've got a lot of property
developments going on with buying pieces
of land getting planning permission and
i'm excited by the profits but more than
anything
i'm 30 years old i've been in the game
12 years i've made millions of pounds
and you can check me check my records
out on company house if you're skeptical
a lot of people say prove this and prove
this and
you know i really haven't got much to
prove um but i think
for me more than getting excited about
making money it's more about for me
lifestyle and living the life that i
really enjoy living a life that's
fulfilling
pulling people up most of my family
members are now very successful in
property a lot of my best friends are i
love my life i love my family and for me
if i had to summarize in one word
why i do youtube videos why i have a
training company in one word there's
lots of other things but one word would
be fulfillment
fulfillment
satisfaction
life mission legacy i know i'm not going
to be remembered for making a load of
money a lot of people are a lot richer
than i am but i will be remembered for
the people that i helped and
do trainers
property trainers educators have a duty
and obligation and responsibility
absolutely in fact
some people say they think that the
training industry should be regulated
they should have more legislation to
stop the cowboys do you know what i
would campaign for that i think that's
absolutely right i didn't teach a single
property investment course i didn't even
register my training company until first
i was a millionaire and i became a
millionaire from property investment and
property deal sourcing i think that
in 2021 everybody's an expert you know
someone would do one deal or make a
little bit of money in bitcoin and then
suddenly they're an expert and set up a
youtube channel and that's fine but i
think to teach something i think to run
a training business i really feel it has
a lot of responsibility i think you
should have been in the industry at
least five years i think you should have
a good proven track record
if you're going to run a training
business it comes with a lot of
headaches comes with a lot of
responsibilities you need staff customer
service complaints procedures you need
insurance
you need to make sure that you're
covered protected you need to make sure
that you're there for your students
come what may and as a company i'm
really proud of our results i'm really
proud of every single winners on a
wednesday every single student that we
have i'm not perfect my company's not
perfect but that is why i am a trainer
thank you so much for watching and i
look forward to seeing you guys next
time